[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
happy wednesday well looks like this is
the part of the revolution where they
start throwing their political opponents
in jail wow that was fast it was just a
week ago they were telling us about
unity remember that
what we didn't know at the time is they
meant that everyone with power should
unite
against the rest of the country unity
meant
oligarchy doug mackey learned that the
hard way this morning mackie is a 31
year old conservative journalist from
florida
at 7 00 a.m fbi agents showed up at
mackey's house they threw him in
handcuffs and they dragged him to a cell
he now faces 10 years in prison his
crime
he made fun of powerful democrats on
social media
as the federal criminal complaint puts
it quote mackie made coordinated use of
social media to spread disinformation
relevant to the impending 2016
presidential election
this disinformation by the
administration solemnly explained
quote often took the form of memes
yes memes online mockery
mockery online is now illegal when it's
aimed at the wrong people
doug mackey hurt their feelings so they
put him in jail
according to joe biden's justice
department doug mackey violated
18 u.s code section 241 he did this by
tricking people like the dastardly
trickster that he is
into not voting in the presidential
election
what's interesting is that prosecutors
showed no evidence whatsoever that doug
mackey actually tricked anyone into
anything
voting or not not a single person
but that doesn't matter shriek cnn doug
mackey is a bad
person with bad views and by the way we
have no idea what doug mackey's views
are
we don't care what cnn is telling us is
that those views are a crime he's a
criminal
lock him up give him a longer sentence
than we give to rapists
which they're trying to do as of tonight
that is the official position of the
lynch mob channel
but hold on a minute as a legal matter
have you ever read
18 us code section 241 probably not but
you should
look it up when you read it you will
learn that joe biden's justice
department is
lying in a very obvious way and that
should make you very nervous
it turns out that federal law does not
ban memes or for that matter
misinformation
whatever that is the law that biden's
prosecutors are citing
instead prohibits quote conspiring to
injure
oppress threaten or intimidate anyone
from exercising the right to vote
according to the law that would include
kidnapping voters invading their homes
sexually abusing them doug mackey didn't
do
any of that not even close to any of
that doug mackey made memes
therefore he's a domestic terrorist
speech is violence dissent is a felony
what you may be wondering does a case
like this mean for the first amendment
well it means that it's effectively
suspended
you can now be arrested for saying the
wrong things and at seven am this
morning one journalist actually was
arrested for that
almost no one tonight seems to be
defending him he had bad thoughts he
deserves it
they think it's okay and that shouldn't
surprise you because we're clearly
living under some form of martial law at
the moment how do we know that well
here's one indication there are nearly
10 000 federal troops in our capital
city tonight oh that's a hint
why are they there how long will they be
staying
no one is being very specific about any
of that so you're left to draw your own
conclusions which people naturally are
and by the way it's not making anyone
more moderate if you're really worried
about extremism you probably wouldn't
put 10
000 federal troops in your capital city
making everyone more radical and crazy
but they don't care about that the point
of this whole highly militarized
exercise is to remind you of what
chairman mao once famously said
political power grows from the barrel of
a gun unfortunately that is true
in every country at all times
connecticut senator chris murphy is no
genius but he does understand that as he
explained today as long as his political
opponents exist
those soldiers will stay the threat to
the country is not
over right we still have 5 000 national
guard members
surrounding the capital complex why
because there are still existing threats
present threats to the security of the
capital
and so so long as donald trump is
empowered by senate republicans there is
still the chance
that he is going to incite another
attempt
at the capitol the threat is still very
real to american democracy
okay so as long as there are people in
this country who persist in disagreeing
with chris murphy
explains chris murphy we're going to
need to keep thousands of heavily armed
soldiers on the scene why specifically
because and we're quoting now
the threat is still very real to
american democracy
but wait democracy requires soldiers we
thought it was voluntary
if you're starting to think that maybe
someone at some point secretly redefined
the term democracy
changing its meaning to roughly 180
degrees from what it was just last year
you may be on to something what we're
looking at now is not
democracy in the classical athenian
sense where everyone gets to vote and
the voice of everyone matters equally
no we're looking at now is in said
democracy in the 1970s
eastern bloc people's democratic
republic sense
this new version of democracy is a
democracy where everyone fervently
agrees with the people in power or else
they go immediately to jail
doug mackey's problem it turns out is
that he didn't properly understand what
democracy is
thankfully congressman tim ryan of ohio
does understand it and he explained it
to us today
we're not letting those soldiers go home
tim ryan said
until they do what our special
operations forces did
in iraq and afghanistan watch this
who in our government and our military
have had
experience around uh crowd control maybe
even
special operations forces in iraq and
afghanistan
like how can we learn everything we need
to learn
to reset the posture on capitol hill
and and we're not gonna let the national
guard
go home uh or we're not not gonna create
an
unsafe environment for the country's
business until we have that figured out
oh
they're specialists in controlling
unruly populations
we get it rather than answer our
questions or improve our lives you're
bringing in people with guns to remind
us
that you're in charge and dissent is
illegal
that's a big change you may have thought
you were a decent american in good
standing ten years ago
nobody in this country would have called
your views extreme they weren't extreme
then
you don't think they're extreme now
you've always considered yourself a
pretty moderate person
live your life and get along with others
oh that's not possible now because the
rules have changed
you are now a dangerous insurgent you
are no different from a bloodthirsty
pashtun in helmand province or an isis
terrorist in erbil
you're part of a guerrilla insurgency or
maybe it's a gorilla conservancy that's
possible too have you seen the pictures
from january 6th
some of those terror leaders seemed
suspiciously furry
here's the mastermind behind that
terrible insurrection the jihadi known
by his nom daguerre
chewbacca guy
[Music]
hey man glad to see you guys you guys
patriots look at this guy he's got
covered in blood god bless you
yes you good sir do you need medical
attention
i'm good thank you all right
i got shot in the face
i got shot in the face with some kind of
plastic bullet any chance i could get
you guys to leave the senate wing
we will i've been making sure i ain't
disrespecting the place okay i just want
to let you guys know this is like
the sacred place
sad news tonight chewbacca guy is no
longer available for your kid's seventh
birthday party he's in prison tonight
we'll tell you when they move him to
gitmo or some undisclosed black site
and when they do sandy cortez will
breathe easier
back during the great terrorist siege of
january 6th sandy cortez found herself
in the same city as chewbacca guy
literally in the same city trapped and
abandoned like
just like those lonely valiant troops in
corregidor so many years ago
she really thought she was going to die
i had a
pretty traumatizing event happen to me
i can tell you that i had a very close
encounter where i thought i was going to
die
so thankfully they've arrested chewbacca
guy and the rest of his marauding band
of terrorists many of them well over 65
years old
so there's still a little justice in
this country but hairy stoners in viking
hats are not the only threat that sandy
cortez faces tonight no far from it
there are the other members of congress
to worry about
some of them are republicans and you
know what that means
at any moment these people are likely to
open fire indiscriminately on the house
floor purely out of racism
and of course she's worried about that
listen we still don't yet feel
safe around other members of congress
i think a very considerable amount the
moment
you bring a gun onto the house floor in
violation of rules
you put everyone around you in danger i
don't care if you accidentally set it
off
i don't care if you intentionally set it
off i don't know if you don't set it off
at all
you are put you are endangering the
lives
of members of congress and it is
absolutely
outrageous that we even have to have
this conversation
it's outrageous absolutely outrageous
said the leader of america's narcissism
party the fastest growing party in the
country
even on the house floor surrounded by
other elected members of congress
democratically elected
sandy cortez did not feel safe and that
my friends is why we need
tens of thousands of armed federal
troops right outside her office tonight
so that sandy cortez can finally for
once take a breath and get back to the
vital business of making perky instagram
videos about herself
the business of the people it must go on
well of course it must we all support
that though now that we're
talking about the people you've got to
wonder what they think of all of this
the actual
people no one in power cares what they
think
obviously none of this is about the
people who are actually
suffering in our country the millions of
them no
we're watching one of those rare
revolutions rare in world history that's
being waged
not on behalf of the general population
but waged against
it all of this is being done expressly
for the oligarchs none of it is being
done for you
of course if you live in washington dc
you already knew that very well
federal troops are not protecting your
home tonight
sandy cortez doesn't care if you get
robbed or carjacked as more and more
people are as crime
skyrockets sandy cortez and her friends
want to abolish
your police not their police here's a
scene from the rest of the city of
washington
carmelo duncan was 15 months old when he
was fatally shot wednesday night in
southeast
his father was driving the vehicle and
the toddler was strapped into his car
seat when he was struck with bullets
the preliminary investigation point out
at least two people opened fire on the
car
as it drove by southern ave hitting the
car at least 10 times
the toddler was struck with bullets in
his car seat
right next to his father this happened
in washington dc within
walking distance of the capitol but no
one inside that domed building the ones
who were so afraid of chewbacca man
noticed or cared so whatever else you
conclude from this
this tale of two cities to dip into the
cliche bin for a moment
here's one thing you can be certain of
it's not actually violence that sandy
cortez and her fellow democrats are
worried about
no it's something else so why are all
those federal troops
at the capitol